I have a very disturbing story for you
today about guns and race and good guys
with guns that we have to talk about and
and there is this very racialized
pro-gun argument that is sometimes made
around people of color and guns
sometimes you hear this from from the
pro-gun right when they want to pretend
as though the NRA is not an
extraordinarily racially tinged
organization and what they say is this
is their argument not mine we want
everybody to have access to legal guns
including people of color and the reason
it's important for people of color to
have legal access to guns is that they
are more likely to live in dangerous
neighborhoods and sometimes they have
more of a need to defend themselves
against other people who are violent
that's sort of the argument that you
hear them make and yet we rarely hear
about the NRA coming to the public
defense of black people who had firearms
or used firearms for self-defense or
merely had guns on them when they had an
interaction with the police we've even
had some specific cases we've covered in
the last year and a half that I've told
you about where you had legal a gun
ownership by black Americans that got
them into trouble when they were stopped
by police and in many of those the NRA
literally said nothing that's the sort
of pretext the context cut to this
weekend in Illinois 26 year-old black
man Jamel Roberson was working security
at a bar called Manny's Blue Room in the
Chicago suburb of Robbins Illinois there
was a shooting at the bar and Jamel
robbed Roberson Roberson was there
working security like I said Roberson
was able to apprehend the shooter and
when police showed up they shot and
killed the black security guard Jamel
Roberson who had again apprehended the
actual shooter the police were called
and were responding to the officer who
killed Roberson is white and you be the
judge of whether that's a factor as we
talk about the story the way that it
went down
is that Roberson had asked some drunk
people at the bar to leave a common
occurrence at bars one of those drunk
people came back with a gun and started
shooting Roberson was able to get the
shooter down on the ground with his knee
on the shooters back to prevent him from
getting up and according to what I've
read had taken the shooters gun and was
holding it on the shooters back along
with his knee waiting for police to
arrive now there is one report that says
Roberson had his own gun as well as a
valid firearms ID card the other reports
say that it was the shooters gun that
Robertson Roberson had appropriated for
himself but either way when police
showed up he had the suspect down on the
ground knee on his back gun on his back
police show up and shoot the security
guard dead as people were reportedly
reportedly yelling he's security he's
security the police who are now
investigating say that when police
showed up they yelled at the security
guard dropped the gun dropped the gun
and eventually shot him dead they also
say that part of the confusion was that
Roberson wasn't wearing any clothing
that identified him or indicated that he
was working security although there is a
conflicting report which says he had a
hat that said security at the same time
a lot of people just wear hats that say
security or shirts that say security
that's become popular so where that
plays into this is not totally clear
right now a lawsuit has been filed
claiming that Roberson civil rights were
violated this now is going to extend for
a long time with this legal case and
also notable here and tragic is that the
actual shooter in the initial bar
shooting as of this morning hadn't yet
been charged so my question is where's
the nra on this Roberson had a valid
federal of firearms identification card
he did not have a concealed carry
license we heard from the Midlothian
Illinois police chief what we have
learned is Jamel Roberson was a brave
man who was doing his best to end an
active shooter situation at this bar so
what are we to make of this Pat because
the defenders of the police are saying
listen police
were called to an active-shooter
situation they show up and a man is
kneeling on another man's back with a
gun pointed at him any reasonable police
officer would say oh we were called to a
shooting we see a guy with a gun that's
the shooter let's do something about it
but is it actually that simple if the
officer had been black or the security
guard white would it have played out the
exact same way and I don't deny for a
second Pat and you come from a law
enforcement family Pat there's no
question that a quick judgment has to be
made by police in these situations and
the issue here is whether that quick
judgment was in any way influenced by
race and I don't know whether we will
ever actually have that answer well
certainly the NRA doesn't want to cross
paths with law enforcement because they
do make up its base of supporters but I
mean there are many examples this is
just the latest one two years ago
falando Casteel a black man driving in
minnesota was pulled over by a white
police officer and he did the right
thing falando Castille did he said that
I have a gun on me I just want to make
sure that you know and then he reached
for I don't know if it was his phone or
his license and registration he reached
for something and the cop said don't
reach for it don't reach for it and shot
him dead
so his civil rights were also violated
no due process there he followed the
formula for what you're supposed to do
if you're pulled over and you have a gun
on you and yet he was shot dead and the
nra stayed silent on that one too
I want to hear from you about this what
do you make of it we are going to be
posting some comments that we receive on
this story on the david pakman show
instagram page at david pakman show
while you're there you can follow me at
David Pakman we will take a quick break
and be back after this with our
investigation into what is the solution
to the social media free speech D
platforming problem that many say we
have that's next